مشاهدينا الكرام بعد لحظات فقط
لاقرار الرئيس الفرنسي
بيتراجع اللغه الفرنسيه في الدول المغربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا مشاهدينا الكرام
الرئيس الفرنسي
على هامش الدوله الثامنه عشر لقمه
الفرانكفونيه بجزيره جربه التونسيه بان
استعمالا اللغه الفرنسيه تراجع في الدول
المغاربيه مشددا على ضروره السعاده
هي مشاهدينا الكرام عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
من تونس السيد الحبيب بن صالحه رئيسه
ومخبر الدراسات المغربي
والتواصل الثقافي في كليه الاداب والفنون
والانسانيات بمنوبه اهلا بك ومرحبا سيد
الحبيب بن صالح وشكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه
هذه الدعوه
شكرا جزيلا
مرحبا مرحبا
في علوم التربيه واللغات بجامعه محمد
الخامس بالرباط اهلا بكم ومرحبا سيد حسن
المادي والكل شكرا جزيلا لك ايضا على
تربيه هذه الدار
شكرا سيدي على الاستضافه واهلا وسهلا
بالمشاهدين الكرام ومرحبا
بضيفك الكريم مرحبا بكم جميعا ماكو من
جربه التونسيه على هذا مش هذه القمه قمه
الفرانفونيه يقرر بتراجع اللغه الفرنسيه
في المنطقه
المغاربيها قبل 20 او 30 عاما ما حقيقه
هذا الامر نبدا بالتشخيص هل فعلا تراجعت
اللغه الفرنسيه في المنطقه المغاربيه يطرح
عليك السؤال اولا همم من تونس السيد حبيبي
بن صالح رئيس مخابر دراسات المغاربيه
والتواصل الثقافي مرحبا من جديد
هذا تسريح غريب كان بيودينا محاوله رئيس
ماكرون على موجات التلفزه الوطنيه الناطقه
بالفرنسيه كانت قديما تنطق بلغات العالم
على كل حال في اعتقادي ومرحبا بضيفينا من
المغرب اولا قبل كل شيء او اللغه لا
تتراجع اللغه انا مولود بمدينه اللمسه
اكلت في مدينه تتكلم اللاتينيه هناك همم
جميله وقال العثور عليها تحمل اللغه
اللاتينيه اذا زودته تعليمي في مدرسه
الابتدائيه بلمسه بالفرنسيه وبالعربيه
والمعرفه ثانوي بالانجليزيه ودرسته فرنسيه
كليه الاداب والفنون والانسانيات بمنوبه
ابن الاذاعه تونس الدولي ليه تتعامل معه
خمس لغات قال فرنسيه
الانجليزيه
الالمانيه تتعامل مع الايطاليه والاسبانيه
هذا هذا اولا وقبل كليه جربه رحبت بضيوفها
الكرام من دول الفرانكفونيه كان بيودينا
ان يكون ربما مجالات للحوار لان كل جمله
تقال لها سياق
معين سيد بن صالح بمعنى انهم من وجهه نظرك
لا تراجع عن اللغه الفرنسيه
في المنطقه المغاربيه لا تراجع لاي لغه
كانت هناك هناك المستعمل هناك شباب يتعامل
مع التعادل باللسان بطريقه اخرى ادوات
حديثه على الاستاذ وزميلي من المغرب
غيرته طريقه تدريسي انطلاق من تلك الجمله
طيب
العين المكان
بالمقابل هل فعلا تراجعت اللغه الفرنسيه
لدى شعوب المنطقه المغاربيه واين نلحق ذلك
الاكثر هل يتفق ضيفي معك من الرباط مع
طرحك سيد حسن التعليم العالي في علوم
التربيه والغات في جامعه محمد الخامس
بريطات مرحبا لكن الكلمه
شكرا اعتقد بانني لا اوافق الاستاذ الحبيب
على ما قاله
فما قاله السيد مكروه هو الحقيقه هو
الواقع اي ان هناك الان تراجع لهذه اللغه
اللغه الفرنسيه وانه هناك منافسه قويه من
طرف لغات اخرى وخاصه اللغه الانجليزيه
التي اصبحت اليوم هي لغه العلم لغه
التواصل لغه الاقتصاد وبالتالي فانا
بالنسبه لي ان نتمسك الدول المغاربيه
باللغه الفرنسيه لا يزيدها الا مشاكيل
وصعوبات صحيح انه يمكن ان نتواصل باي لغه
من اللغات ولكن اليوم
اللغه الانجليزيه تحتل حيزا كبيرا في مجال
العلمي والمعرفه ومكراه على حق فيما قاله
رئيس دوله كان ربما ينتظر ان يدافع هو على
لغته ولكن اقر بواقع مرير اي ان اللغه
الفرنسيه اليوم ربما قد استنفدت مهمتها في
بلدها في فرنسا وبالتالي اذا فهناك واقع
اخر ينتظر الدول المغاربيه
والاقرار هو سيد الادله حتى تعود اليك سيد
الحبيب بن صالحه رئيس مقبره الدراسات
المغاربيه
والتواصل الثقافي لحظه تطرح عليك السؤال
ما كان يقول انه هناك اسباب سياسيه لهذا
التراجع يعني هو مطلع على الوضع عن كثب
يقول ان هناك اسباب سياسيه لهذا التراجع
ووجود رغبه في استعمال لغات اخرى وكذلك
ايضا وجود لغه انجليزيه سهله الاستعمال
طريقك على مذهب اليه ضيفه هل تفهم انت
اسباب هذا همم التراجع
انا في اعتقادي اولا ارد على زميلي ماذا
يقول ادريس الشرايبي وهو تليق اللسان
ويكتب انطلاق من الانجليزيه الحضاره اماه
كيف نعتبر اللغه الانجليزيه اللي وقعت
تسخيرها بدون شكسبير للتواصل في العالم
هذا غريب هذا لا يعقل اطلاقا اللغات
التجاره تتعامل مع العالم بادوات العالم
لا يعطي اطلاقا ايه
انجليزيه
بالانجليزيه فقط
الانجليزي شمال افريقيا في اعتقادي متعدد
اللسان وقال ذلك القرمادي منذ قديم الزمان
وقال عبد الكبير الخطيبي من يجرؤ الان على
تكلم بلغه فرنسيه واحده كنا بودينا تنظيم
ملتقى الدولي
واللغات الفرنسيه لا يعطي
حضور اللغه العربيه عبد الفتاح وهو مغربي
عندما يكتب المغربي ويتحاوروا او يحاولوا
باللغه الفرنسيه باي لغه يحاور هو يحاور
بالجنسيه والانجليزيه والعربيه
الارقام
الانجليزيه
تراجعت لذلك الرئيس الفرنسي بحاجه الى بعض
الحلول هنا احاول ان اسالك همم الاقرار
واضح كيف سالت من وجهه نظرك هذا
التراجع في استخدام اللغه الفرنسيه في
المنطقه المغاربيه هل اسباب سياسيه من
وجهه نظرك هل يفسر بتراجع النفوذ
الاقتصادي لفرنس ربما في المنطقه ام
لتراجع اللغه نفسها في مجالات البحث
العلمي ام لعوامل اخرى كيف تركب انت
باختصار شديد ذلك سيد بن صالحه قبل ان
اعطي كلمه لضيفي السيد حسن
انا اعتقد ان لو زار زميل المغربي جربه
وشاهد طلب وتلاميذ همم خلال النص كده
الطاهر بن جلول يعني لا يعقل له انا لا
اوافق على تراجع اي لغه كانت اقول ان الان
رهيبه الان هي تصلح للتلميذ الطالب وهو لا
يستعمل المنجد علينا مراجعه الطرق انت
تقول هناك سياسيه
هي الاهم هو الذي يقول انا لا اقول فقط
هو اسس اسس الى مجمع اللغه الفرنسيه
مجمع اللغه الفرنسيه كان الاستاذ
عنده يتربى في مدينه اليوم ويتعلم اللغه
بسرعه لا يعقل من يحكم على من من يقيم من
حتى المحكم من يحكم في من ماذا
انسانيه اللغه الفرنسيه
اين انسانيه فرانكفونيه طيب سيد بن صالحه
ااه اطرح عليك السؤال سيد احسن نادي استاذ
التعليم العالي في علوم التربيه واللغات
بجامعه محمد الخامس برباط يجب ان نفهم هذا
الاقرار من رئيس الفرنسي الذي مبني صراحه
على معطيات ملموسه حتى اللغه الفرنسيه احد
المسؤولين قالها هذاك اليوم انا تراجعت
حتى في المؤسسات الدوليه على سبيل المثال
سيد الاحسن المادي بشكل ملموس الجزائر لم
تختار اللغه الفرنسيه لاولاقها النقديه
الورقيه الجديده المغرب اتجه الى اعتماد
تدريس اللغه الانجليزيه ابتداء من الصف
الاول الابتدائي وصححني ان كنت مخطئا وهنا
كثيرون يسالون عن الاسباب هل هي ثوره
تربويه تعليميه كما توصف ام انها قد تكون
قرارا سياسيا ايضا كما قال الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون نفسه
[موسيقى]
هي هي في الحقيقه الامر
الانتقال من
مرحله الى مرحله جديده
واعتقد بانه لا يجب ان نتعامل مع هذا
الموضوع بنوع من العواطف وميناء الوجدان
والتاريخ ربما قد مر يجب ان ننظر الى الى
المستقبل ونهيئه انفسنا للمستقبل
فجامعاتنا سواء في تونس او في المغرب او
في الجزائر اناشيد بانها تخلفت كثيرا عن
في الترتيب ديال الجامعات العالميه
لسبب بسيط وان اغلبيه الاساتذه المتواجدين
في هذه في هذه الجامعات لا يستطيعون ان
ينشرون مقالاتهم العلميه
في المجلات الكبيره التي لها سيط عالمي
الابداعات كذلك نفس الشيء اذا هناك مشاكل
بمعنى اخر ان العالم كله يتجه الى اللغه
الانجليزيه
واعتقد هذا وعد ما وعى به المغرب والجزائر
وتونس كذلك ربما بدون استاد الحبيب بن
صالح الذي يحب اللغه الفرنسيه وهذا من حقه
فهو استاذ اللغه الفرنسيه ولكن الواقع شيء
شيء اخر نريد اذا اولا نعطي مكانه مهمه
للغه العربيه التي هي لغتنا وجزء كبير من
هوتنا وهذا ما نقوم به في المغرب وكذلك
للامازيغيه لانها لغه رسميه كذلك بالنسبه
لدستورنا
لكن لكي نهيء المستقبل لكي نهيء اقتصادا
قويا لكي نهيء كفاءات قويه التي يمكن ان
تحاور العالم علينا اذا بهذه اللغه الاخرى
للتواصل والاقتصاد والعلمي والمعرفه ويقول
لك سيد لحسن المادي حتى تعود السيد الحبيب
بن صالح وربما فهم انه ربما يصعب عليك
الاقرار بتراجع هذه اللغه في المنطقه
المغاربيه بشكل عام يقول لك لا يجب
التعامل مع هذا الموضوع بمنطقه العواطف
والوجدان الحديث ليس حديثا عن اقصاء لغه
بعينها ولكن يقول لك
عفوا فقر عليك السؤال سيد صالح اللغه
اللغه العصر لغه المستقبل في المنطقه
المغاربيه هي فعلا له لغه الابحاث لغه
العلم لغه التطور وان في هذه المرحله
المنطقه المغاربيه تحتاج الى كفاءات من
اجل النهوض بهذه المنطقه واحنا سبل هي ان
تكون اللغه الانجليزيه موجوده في اطار
تعدد اللغات هل تفهم انت هذه الحجج بعيدا
عن هذا الامر غريبه ورفضك مساله تراجع
اللغه هل تفهم ان ال ال الوقف في الوقت
الحادث اما تحاجه الى الاتجاه في المقررات
والمناهج العلميه نحو اللغه الانجليزيه
لانها لغه العصر كما تفعل نفسها فرنسا في
دائره الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى
من بعض المسؤولين الفرنسيين التعاطي
والتعامل باللغه الانجليزيه تفضل سيد
الحبيب بن صالح
انا ودافع على التوازن التوازن التوازن
يعني ان اتكلم الانجليزيه واكتبه
بالانجليزيه ولا يعقل اطلاقا تضخيم
الامر لان التعامل مع الحداثه وكل ما هو
محكم لو كان بركسون اقترح نص نص حول الضحك
الى مجله امريكيه محكمه ربما وقع رفض في
هذا العمل في امريكا يقال ان نشروا او
الموت ونحن ندافع على
التعادليه لتوفيق الحكيم
التوحيد يقول الكلام على الكلام صعب لا
يعقل اطلاقا طاهر بن جلول هناك شرطه
المرور وهناك شرطه الحدود همم لا يوجد لا
يوجد شرطه اللغات كيف يعقل تفخيم جيه على
حسابي شيء قلت التوازن علينا استعمال
ادوات العالم
امس بجربه ولد سجنان كانت له اله حديثه
فقلت لل لصاحب المشروع المهندس باي لغه
تتحدث الان قال بلغات
العالميه عن سؤالي عفوا هل تعتبر
او تتفق مع الطرح الذي يقول
لو سمحت
هل تعتبر ان اللغه الانجليزيه هي فعلا لغه
العصر لغه العلم في هذه المرحله ضيف يتحدث
عن البحوث العلميه التي ربما يجد البعض
صعوبه في نشرها حتى باللغه همم الفرنسيه
هل تتفهم مقتضيات المرحله من وجهه نظر
ضيفي الذي يقول ان الزمن غير الزمن دائما
في اطار عدم اقصاء اي لغه بعينه لا تبقى
هي ثراء للانسانيه جمعاء هل تتفق مع هذا
سيدنا صالح على الانجليزيه على هذا السؤال
تحديدا وبدقه لو سمحت
عندما نبحث عن الاكسجين الاكسجين بكل لغه
العالم ابدا لا اقبل هذا الراي اعتبروا ان
اللغات قلت فيها حوار وان الانجليزيه بدون
شكسبير بدون شعور ابو القاسم الشابي عشب
الشعوري والشعوري باننا دنياك كون وهواتف
بشعون اين انسانيه اللغات كيف يعقل اعتبار
العلم بدوني يقاله
ثلاثه وخراب العلم له الياته اللي كتب ذلك
في الحضاره الحضاره اماه عبد الكبير
الخطيبي كتب ياسين قال لي فئرانسا اتكلم
بالفرنسيه افضل من الفرنسيه لاقول الى
فلان فانني جزائري عندما حاولت الجزائر
حدث في اللغه الفرنسيه وتعويني ذلك في
اللغه العربيه
بالاعتماد على تجربه مصر كان ذلك ربما مات
تراجع في اعتقادي لا يجب تضخيم اللغه
علينا
الالمانيه الصينيه الكوريه علينا زميلي
على الامازيغيه فعلا فعلا انما نقول تنصن
همم البرتقاله تمصل سيمسيو تومسن عندما
نقول كليمانتين سيميسيو كليما عندما نقول
بل تكون فهذه الايطاليه عندما نقول وكلمه
الكريم مراجعه بعض المعتاد احنا في لمتى
يخرجوا من النساء
سعودي
نحو اللغه الانجليزيه سيد الاحسن المادي
همم استاذ التعليم العالي جامعه محمد
الخامس
هاته الاجيال التي تدرس الان والتي بدات
الشابه التي بدات تتجه اكثر فاكثر نحو
اللغه الانجليزيه وثمت دراسات تثبت هذا
الامر يعني رئيس فرنسي لم ينطلق من عدم
حين تحدث لانه تم اطراف اخرى ما زالت
متشبثه باللغه الفرنسيه كاللغه اساسيه
وكلوغه حيه ثانيه بعد اللغه
العربيه في المناهج التعليميه وفي حتى في
الادارات الى غير ذلك كيف ترقب انت هذا
الامر حينما يقول الرئيس انه يجب ان يكون
هناك برنامج همم
استرداد لمكانه اللغه الفرنسيه على جزء من
هذا البرنامج هو ااا ربما
رفض البعض لي القبول
بهذا الواقع الجديد
والتمسك بالواقع السابق تفضل السيد لحس
المهدي
شكرا قبل الاجابه اعتقد بان الاستاذ
الحبيب تمكنت منه اللغه الفرنسيه ولا
يستطيع الى حد الان
انسلخ عن عن هذا عن هذا الماضي مع كامل
للاسف بالنسبه
لا ننتظر من السيد مكروه ان يضع لنا
المناهج او ان يقول لنا بماذا سنقوم فنحن
اولا همم دوله مستقله اخذنا استقلالنا في
بدايه الخمسينات
وكان ربما الاستعمار فعل بالدول المغاربيه
ما ما ما فعل وهي الان بدات في التحرر من
هذه الصيد السيطره اللغويه كذلك وحينما
اقول السيطره من اللغويات لا اعني باننا
سنقتل اللغه الفرنسيه بل اللغه الفرنسيه
ستبقى كذلك من بين اللغات ولكن ستخذه فقط
مكانتها من في المناهج ونعطي الاهميه اذا
هنا للغه العربيه واللغه الامازيغيه ولكن
لغه المستقبل لغه التنميه لغه الحداثه لغه
التواصل العالمي هي اللغه الانجليزيه
ومكرو واعي كل الوعي بهذه بهذه الاشياء
لذلك اقر في مؤتمر جرب بذلك فليففهم سر
الحبيب ما قاله مكرو هذا شانه لا يريد ان
يفهم ذلك فهذا كذلك شانه ولكن المستقبل
والتنميه والتقدم والحضاره الانسانيه كلها
تتجه الى ايجاد لغه
للتواصل العالمي لخلق اذا التنميه في هذه
البلدان طيب وتحرر من السيطره لغويه وكانه
نوع من الاستقلال
اللغوي كلمه الختام لك سيد الحبيب بن
صالحه في اطار حديث رئيس الفرنسيه عن
برنامج استرداد مكانه اللغه
الفرنسيه في العالم
انا اهديت اطروحات الدكتوره دوله
الانشائيه والتناس الى رئيس ماكرون هديت
له الكتاب واتمنى ان يقرا او يعيد قراءه
كتب ياسين انا دفعته على التعدد اللساني
بما في ذلك الانجليزيه وقلت علينا ان
نتعامل مع الحداثه بدون تنجيم وتكه ولا
ولا مع احترامي لزميله لا يمكن اطلاقا
اعتبار ما يقع احيانا في بلد واحنا كنا
نحترم بالقرارات السياديه هو الطريق
الوحيد في اللغه الفرانكونيه بانسانيتها
لها ان تصنع نفسها من جديد كاي موروث
لساني وادبي اللغه الفرنسيه لغه فلتين مش
لغه نابوليا هي اللغه الادب لغه
الانجليزيه
والعربيه اللغه التوحيدي والجاحظ فلنا لن
نستمع الى ام كلثوم واذا جاك بريال
زميلي العزيز لا لا نتعامل
بيتحدث عن الاجيال باكملها
الشباب
المستقبل
اكاديميه الى المغرب اخر كتاب صدرها هذه
الخاتمه اخر كتاب صدرها يعني الواحد مبروك
من جماعه جديده هو كتاب تونسي جزائري
مغربي عنوانه التعدد الانساني
طيب همم كنت قد بدات مع سيد الحبيب بن
صالح
كنت قد بدات مع السيد حبيب بن صالحه ولكن
همم لذلك ساعطيك كلمه الختام سيد لحسن
مادي اعتذر منك باختصار شديد في حتى في 30
ثانيه واختم معك تعقب على ضيف السيد حبيب
بن صالح ونختم معك هذه الحلقه سيد حسن
مهدي
نعم شكرا اولا شكرا للاستاذ همم الحبيب بن
صالح على هذه الكلمات الرقيقه في حقي بلدي
العزيز وانا لا اقول لك الا تستمع الى كل
هذه الى هذا التنوع الغنائي ولكن نتكلم عن
بناء المستقبل وعن بناء الاجيال هؤلاء
الاجيال الذي في حقيقه الامر ضيعوا وقتا
كثيرا وكثيرا جدا في تعلم لغه واحده هي
اللغه الفرنسيه حان الوقت الان لكي يكون
هناك لغه العالم لغه التواصل لغه الاقتصاد
وان تكون لغتنا هي لغه التنميه سواء
بالنسبه للمغرب او بالنسبه للجزائر او
بالنسبه لتونس وكذلك موريتانيا
من تونس العاصمه سيد الحبي ابن صالح رئيس
مخبر الدراسات المغاربيه فرانكفورنيا
المقرنيه والتواصل الثقافيه ومن الرباط
السيد لحسن ماديا التعليم العالي في علوم
التربيه والغات بجامعه محمد الخامس
بالرباط كنتم معنا في فقره وجها لوجه